bonjour nadia janvier prochain
doctorante en sociologie et membre de
génération quoi projet avec les chaînes
de notre réseau pour mieux connaître la
jeunesse de nos pays un projet qui après
france télévisions en france fait son
apparition dans nos régions
la diège son ville génération quoi
génération watts génération pourquoi
génération qui savent exactement alors
le terme peut-être un petit peu
surprenant génération wad génération
quoi bon alors il faut il faut se rendre
compte que on travaille sur une
génération qui a aujourd'hui entre 18 et
34 ans et je ne sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez mais quand on était ados quand
vos enfants ou vos proches avaient de ce
qu'ils ont cet âge là étaient ados ils
disent at il parlé comme ça quoi tu sais
quoi en fait
on va aller la radio qu'on va parler de
génération quoi quoi tu vois quoi hein
quoi
ouais quoi voilà c'était un truc
vachement à la mode donc c'est déjà ça
mais surtout la deuxième partie de
l'histoire c'est que à travers cette
enquête ce seront aux jeunes eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire aux personnes de cette
génération de déterminer le nom de leur
génération
mais vous êtes sûr que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui disent croire évidemment
évidemment que non c'est à dire qu'on
c'est à dire qu'on essaie de se dire
qu'elle a été un mot qui a été marquant
dans cette génération et ça a été un mot
qu'ils ont utilisés un moment mais de
façon c'est provisoire parce qu'à la fin
de ce sondage dont on va parler du
sondage de génération quoi et bien les
jeunes sont invités à dire eux-mêmes
voilà comment est ce que tu appelleras
génération quel serait le terme que tu
utilises ray par exemple quand on a fait
passer cette enquête au niveau de la
france hexagonale les jeunes avaient
choisi génération précarité par exemple
ou des choses comme ça alors on attend
encore état d'esprit ça va démontrer
d'année du jeu le but du jeu c'est quand
même de savoir qui sont ces jeunes
corses mundo ce qu'ils ressentent
comment ils ressentent les choses dans
tous les domaines que ce soit familial
que ce soit sociétal que ce soit tout
bagage ouais exactement justement à quoi
tu vois quoi
ouais tu vois bien quoi en fait
effectivement cette enquête n'est pas
juste une enquête statistique donc je
rappelle qu'il va falloir se rendre sur
internet vous allez recevoir plein
d'infos sur la question dans les médias
et répondre à une série de questions
tirées au hasard sur une pente comme il
ya une liste de 140 question mais
rassurez-vous vous aurez pas répondre à
140 question l'ordinateur va vous va
vous envoyer de façon aléatoire un
certain nombre de questions sur l'action
de cette rescrit ou d'avoir été choisis
comme en ce moment non non non non on
vous invite cordialement à bien vouloir
y aller en vous montrant quelques temps
je reçois une invitation sur
l'ordinateur que j'ai rien demandé mais
non mais non mais non mais non vous
écoutez martinique 1ère vous recevez
vous vous suivez cette émission parce
que vous l'aimez beaucoup et du coup
vous apprenez qu'il y a un site sur
lequel vous pourrez vous rendre à partir
de journaux avaient 18 les 18 24 ans et
peut-être pas la cible de la partie mais
non moi j'écoute mart et une première
cela dit je vous assure que vous aurez
il se sera pas seulement à travers un
article 1er il y aura aussi des affiches
dans la l'université dans les écoles
dans les lycées qui voudront bien les
maîtres donc y aura une grosse promotion
pour encourager les personnes qui ont
entre 18 et 34 ans à se rendre sur le
site pour répondre à l' enquête
alors ces questions une fois qu'on aura
répondu ça permettra de savoir quoi ça
servirait à quoi
alors les 120 questions
s'étendent sur énormément de domaines et
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup en tant que
sociologue puisque j'aurai la charge
d'analyser les résultats c'est c'est de
connaître mieux cette génération qui est
particulièrement touchée par les
migrations en martinique c'est à dire
que bon la tranche d'âge 18 34 un peu
bizarre pour tout vous dire d'un point
de vue sociologique ses larges mais ce
qui est intéressant est là où c'est
vraiment super qu'ils aient choisi cette
tranche d'âge là c'est qu'elle colle
presque parfaitement avec la population
déficitaire martinique elle savait qu'on
a un gros problème démographique crocro
le voc a un gros creux se fait vraiment
un énorme creux il nous manque
allez à la louche à peu près vingt mille
personnes disparues dans la nature etc
le problème c'est que nous allons
vraiment en avoir besoin de ces
personnes là voilà donc s'il y a un
problème démographique et les personnes
qui ont entre 18 et 34 ans en martinique
ce sont des personnes qui dans les
prochaines décennies vont avoir un rôle
absolument majeur pour l'avenir de notre
pays de le savoir comme quel est leur
état d'esprit est fondamentale
alors cette sociologue nadia champville
entrons dans le vif du sujet avec
notamment cet aspect des choses qui me
gêne un petit peu
pourquoi parler de jeunesse ultramarines
déjà vous demandez à ces personnes qui
risquent de répondre à vos à votre
enquête de se situer par rapport à
quelque chose qui se trouvent de l'autre
côté
alors tout d'abord la ferme ultramar a
tout d'abord c'est pas mon enquête un
triomphe j y participer oui on m'a
demandé si je voulais bien analyser les
résultats je n'ai pas besoin de 6 et de
martinique et ne veulent pas être
considérés comme des ultramarins le
marais c'est l'autre celui qui de
l'autre côté de la fin je suis je suis
je suis tout à fait d'accord sur le
point sur ce point le terminera marin
c'est un terme qui vient de paris pour
désigner l'autre c'est-à-dire pour
désigner ceux qui sont à l'extérieur 2
de même pas juste le même pas juste de
l'hexagone parce que la corse a imité
par eux tout à fait l'outre-mer on dit
pas l'outre-mer
donc en fait les lorsque l'on a
interrogé le premier panel qui était
filmé et donc vous allez voir quelques
modules vous allez voir les jeunes qui
ont accepté de témoigner à visage
découvert lorsque l'on a fait ce premier
pas mais on a vu que les jeunes se
reconnaissaient pas dans ce terme
ultramarins il ya une question qu'on
vous pose à un moment est ce que vous
considérez que les outre mers partagent
le même destin pour l'instant j'ai
l'impression que les jeunes ne considère
pas qu'il partage le même destin dans le
point de vue imaginons par exemple
pourraient pas par exemple dire qu'il ya
une nation ultramarines que nous sommes
tous et toutes nous taxons par contre
par contre ils ont conscience qu'ils le
partage des mêmes les mêmes aspirations
c'est un certain nombre d' aspiration
commune de qui des aspirations communes
entre les martiniquais et d'autres et
d'autres personnes qui vivent par
exemple en nouvelle calédonie ou en
guyane ou à la réunion ils savent qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas au même culture ce
ne sont pas les mêmes peuples mais ils
partagent les aspirations quand même
préciser que c'est dans le volet
consacré à nos régions que cette notion
de l'identité apparaît en bas ça s'est
pas fait dans l'enquêté qui était menée
au niveau hexagonal a évidemment vous
pensez bien que ce sont des choses qui
intéressent je pense que les que ce soit
en france télévisions mais aussi les le
gouvernement qui je travaille j'imagine
un oeil
doit se demander ce qu'il ya dans la
tête des jeunes de cette génération et
j'espère qu'ils se le demande parce que
c'est très important joué par les deux
premiers panel qui a répondu aux
questions qu'est-ce qu'ils répondent de
finalement qu'il se sente français en
même temps martiniquais alors ces panels
avec un original it2 c'était
promotionnelle donc du coup les jeunes
ont répondu vous allez voir les modules
et ça a été filmé je rappelle que les
encadrants va bien
l'enquète a été fait l enquête à
laquelle vous allez répondre
elle est lé anonymat mais là entre que
ceux qui ont été filmés il était il
était prudent
un rapport un rapport à l'hexagone qui
est assez utilitariste ils ont
conscience que bon dans l'utérus dans
l'état dans l'état actuel des choses
c'est intéressant de se trouver dans
cette situation institutionnelle
il respecte et il adhère aussi aux
valeurs que la république leur propose
si et seulement si ces valeurs restent
ce qu'elles sont ça reste à voir si
elles le resteront
au delà de cette question identitaire
qu'est-ce qui remonte le plus déjà qu à
partir de ce premier panel qui sont les
les aspirations qui sont les envies de
nos jeunes ah ça pour l'instant le
premier panel ne me permettrais pas de
vous donner des réponses précises
il ya vraiment très peu de deux
témoignages pour l'instant et je ne
voudrais pas dire de bêtises si vous
voulez alors on va alors le timing
maintenant ça donnera quoi le timing
quand est ce qu'on aura écoutez la
totalité de cette étude le produit fini
sera quant à elle ce sera l'année
prochaine en fin fin 2017 on va avoir
d'abord la prod la partie ça va ça va
durer six mois vous aurez pendant six
mois l'an quête sera sera ouverte
et puis après il y aura la phase
d'analysé des résultats je pense que
dans le dernier trimestre de 2010 est on
pourra rendre vraiment une copie finale
avec une analyse complète des résultats
vous êtes doctorante en sociologie suite
est effrayant c'est passionnant surtout
que nous sommes dans une société qui est
qui qui acquit rempli de paradoxes et et
de problématiques très très complexe et
du coup c'est très enthousiasmant de
participer à une période en mouvements
de notre société vous demanderez aux
plus âgés au plus vieux de regarder ce
qui se passe à pontivy mans avec cette
étude
oui je crois parce que il faut qu'on
prend
que cette population est sujette à
l'immigration que c'est grave et que les
générations plus âgées aussi leur part
de responsabilité de comprendre pourquoi
les jeunes de cette génération ont
tendance à quitter leur territoire c'est
important pour essayer de l'infléchir
les choses sur la génération qui vient
l'enjeu de cette enquête c'est peut-être
de trouver une solution pour ceux qui
ont moins de 18 ans génération c'hoat
génération trois générations qui ça
merci vous complétez avec nos détergents
ville rappelle que vous êtes doctorante
en sociologie que vous êtes partie
prenante de ce projet génération avec
les chaînes autres mais à merci